[Music]
do you guys find pedantic people
annoying
yes shallow and pedantic semantics don't
know what that means just a family guy
stickler for things dancing is like
isn't it like the crazy or like they're
like a lot like the dancer kiss we only
know the reference look as usual there's
six brains in here and we don't know
what the [ __ ] word is look I'll give
you the actual definition but for as far
as I know it's someone who's like really
like on the okay a put a pendant mm good
answer well they take out the in the
tick they take that out
okay it's a person who is excessively
concerned with formalism accuracy and
precision precision precision one that
makes one who makes an ostentatious and
arrogant show of learning whole
definition was from our and I'm very
smart on reddit twenty three-year-old
just graduated college like let me use
on my college yeah I've done this before
but type that a whole thing and then
just picked out words most like let me
look up synonym for that yeah and
patience in here I used to use the [ __ ]
out of ostentatious cuz I learned it in
ninth grade and I thought it was the
most beautiful word I was just like
that's ostentatious you know who does
[ __ ] like that as a psychology major yes
I can tell you what's going on right now
in my psych class yes what you're going
through right now is called a parabola
and then everyone's like what that's a
bunch of hyperbole that is my table
it's a pound room what you just said the
pound room I don't know but I know
people like that
no okay no we're talking about a person
or just like a thing like a general
concept just a general there's always a
psych students they're like well as a
psychic I'm a psychic
my tarot readings are free of charge
until you want to know what you should
do after
Jeter goes to a college with bars on a
window and a neon okay reddit both so we
have an MIT s hold people try to use the
creative writing skills oh yeah
well people are [ __ ] blog on that this
is the title MIT [ __ ] for telling
people that my girlfriend and I have
been together for one year if she thinks
it's six years wait I like to okay I
like to do these sometimes I like to do
a preamble judgment and just based off
of the off of the title cuz if we're
wrong wrong but based on for that yes
yeah the [ __ ] that's all yeah I'm
gonna say yes
i'ma say no you guys don't know if she's
dealing with something it could be like
a 50 first dates thing so here we're
judging the book by the cover well
there's our fans like I was just saying
I give them a benefit of the doubt I'm
gonna say America is where everybody's
innocent don't forget it said bully
bully bully to believe oh yeah oh yeah
liebelei bully no all right hit us with
the facts what's going on we gonna beat
his ass or not gonna read it because the
way he writes it is just annoying
oh no your guy friends my girlfriend and
I technically dated our last year of
high school in all four years of college
however last year when choosing grad
school the one that was the best for my
research interest that was realistic for
entry and I had already Phenix up to two
was three states away my girlfriend and
I had a big argument argument about it
we ended up she was angry that I was
choosing to move far away and broke up
with me during the argument we ended up
cooling down in agreeing to try
long-distance and got back together
during that same argument it ended up
not mattering because I actually got
accepted to a closer school we both
thought that we were together for six
years until now but I realized that's
not actually true I recently read a
philosophy book yeah
J Thomas of Meech a book about vagueness
about vagueness of language and how we
mostly just use in exact descriptions of
things and that any true Clara Clara
clarity is impossible using human
language but that we should still strive
for precision whenever possible I
thought that was interesting and now I
realize it's not exactly true to say
that my girlfriend and I have been
together for six years if someone asked
you how long I hate this guy's dream
this is how long your students you
wouldn't say that it was six inches if
you had a one inch piece of string and a
five inch piece of string they're two
different things if someone wanted to
know the sum of the lengths of your
string they'd ask that but the actual
question as well as someone asking for
the length of the relationship implies
continuous measurement not a discrete
sum my girlfriend vehemently disagrees
with that she says that it's pedantic
disrespectful to our relationship it is
yeah and actually communicates less than
I think it does since she feels the need
to correct me every time I say it I
pointed it out that she does it every
time I say he says it more than once
yes to correct me and that I always tell
people that that we dated for a couple
of years before a break thing got back
together if they asked she says that one
and a half hours during an argument
isn't a break and that is stupid oh my
god think that she's in the wrong as the
way she frames it fails to communicate
vital information and she's been framing
it as if my site is silly it might be a
school yes dude I want to like he's home
for the run on [ __ ] cent yes Jesus
Christ [ __ ] up committee he's like well
actually he's like one of us well
actually
on medium and and thinks it needs
[ __ ] smart look they get 12 hits on
me he's like I'm a blogger I have a
question
may I please know what the top comment
says oh the top comment question do you
so the top comment says your girlfriend
is right here you're being pedantic
somewhere a pedantic and diminishing
your relationship why do you feel the
need to do this you're the ask let me
say this and this this goes for a lot of
men this is a message there's a little
thing in in business commonly called
risk assessment and you can draw hard
stance over here but on this side you
might die and this is a scenario where I
could kill you Tom bout some six years
to a year this is the guy who's like
wait a minute he wakes up one day he's
like I never technically asked her to be
my girlfriend well that's the thing
technically he's not wrong if he's
saying I don't wait if he said in that
hour I mean in that first argument we
broke up all right a breakup is a
breakup all right it don't matter
because in that I was good like [ __ ] him
I'm doing me I'm living my heart I won't
live a hot girl from [ __ ] somebody
within an hour I'm just saying it
technically you could have right this
reminds me of that prisoner who is
serving life in prison he actually went
into cardiac arrest he died for like 20
seconds and when he and then he came
back and then he was just like okay so
technically I served my life sentence oh
yeah you know I thought but that made me
think of something if I if I ever go
through a breakup i'ma just text my
boyfriend say hot girl summer [ __ ] hey
I mean technically gonna break so it
doesn't matter if it's an hour to have
or it's a year a break is a break so
he's not wrong he's just a douche for
wording it the way he was he could have
been like hey we went together for a
couple years we took a break we got back
not a break was short but it was still
technically a break so there's
information oh that's King how long I've
been with my boyfriend I'm just gonna
[ __ ] say the entire time what yeah
as hell he's very right and an [ __ ]
listen I thought to annoying people like
this a party spinning sucks okay
were you like how long you been with
this person and then well technically my
view but it wouldn't be any like oh god
[ __ ] somebody save me right at the
end of the post does he pull out his
guitar and start playing Wonderwall
[Laughter]
writing in the comments and saying like
you are an [ __ ] because someone who
is asking you that question they don't
want to know that - yes they just want
to know the length of the time you guys
have a cute I feel like it's kind of
like on the spectrum to like not take
into consideration language like
language as a whole it's not just words
it's not just technicalities as a whole
we communicate with like what do you
really ask the intention yeah intentions
it's like you're asking me because you
want some light conversation you don't
want to get into the whole like saying
how are you today yeah actually this
morning I woke up crying exactly blue my
into a tissue and I was like oh my
electrolytes are a little low today yeah
you know my balance has been a little
off it's a little problem in my right
toe but you know for the most part I'd
like to believe I'm okay bye perfect let
me find you a doctor or somebody that
actually gives a [ __ ] yeah gonna be with
you guys again real conversations
apparently because I you guys don't want
to know that's the mentality this person
has they hear people say stuff like that
and then they think it applies to all
conversations they can't they can't
measure the rug this is somebody that
got told that they were smart a lot
growing up and they just couldn't let go
of it like they just couldn't that's all
they have them that's probably all that
they have I want that measured
intelligence by verbage and vocabulary
and lighting rather than how to
communicate it's someone who the teacher
assigns you a [ __ ] group project with
and they're like oh can I please just
work on my own get it done better
that person grew up and that was me I
feel attacked me it's [ __ ] me this is
a guy that got a 94 on his test and
argued with the teacher about it no I
ain't cried to the teacher but a plus
because if you count these two points
that puts it out of ninety-six so that's
over there 95
so technically should be I want a new
group I'm doing all the work here group
projects do suck you hate group projects
do so because that's always one person
that's not gonna do it it's me gets mad
at that person because they were doing
the work this is what kinda text the
teacher after hours and complains about
his group like right when the band's
about the rain he was like you forgot to
collect homework it smells like weed up
here doesn't let you copy their tests to
get a detention for good behavior the
principal's office to tell like you're
not in trouble like yeah but I just
thought you should know that playing
dice in a bathroom on the second floor
give the citizens arrest
he's like the hall monitor
he's the hall monitor and he tightens
his vest very tight every time oh yeah
he seems it there's no lies
mmm-hmm I already know like all of the
comments are about to be lit up with
this is the type of guy oh my god go
into the comments keep it go read all of
them
[Music]